[موسيقى]
هي نتاج طبيعه خلابه وعمل ضخم تفانت فيه
انامل انسان لتولد لنا اجمل الحدائق في
فرنسا في اقليم بجزيره كورسيكا تعد حديقه
ساليتشيا تاج المتوسط جنه منمقه مطله على
البحر تعود لعائلتي بغينوض موستي منذ
1951 هذا المهندس البستاني ابدعها من
العدم
اهيئوا لها مكانا لسقيها واسوي التربه من
حولها في سن الخامسه والثمانين لازال
الرجل يعتني بحديقته يوميا
منطقه ساحره ظلت عذراء بفضلنا نحن الذين
منعنا انشاء مشروع اسكان ضخم عليها يضم
180 مسكنا ومركزا تجاريا مطلا على البحر
ومرحبا كبيرا
في الستينيات انقذت الاسره هذه الارض من
المطورين العقاريين الذين هددوا اشجار
الزيتون بالزواج لكن في عام
1974 اتى حريق مهول على الاخضر واليابس
[موسيقى]
لا زالت اثار الحريق تشهد عليه حتى الان
اتلف كل شيء تقريبا بقيت عشرون شجره زيتون
من اصل 1200 حين راينا لا جاره اختفت بهذه
الطريقه ادركنا استحاله علاجها للاسف لن
نراها مجددا
لمده 25 سنه يصلح وينظف ويعيد تهيئه هذا
المكان يزرعه عن حب ويسقيه من نبع اهتمامه
الدائم حتى اخذت الارض زخرفها وزينت من
جديد تسهر عليها اليوم ابنته ايزابيل
[موسيقى]
الى هذا المكان مع عائلتي عندما كنت صغيره
اقل العديد من الحفلات العائليه هنا في
حديقه
صرت اعمل بها منذ عام
1996 واسهر على تهياتها لذلك انا متعلقه
جدا بها الى الشمال الفرنسي الان وليس
بعيدا عن قمه سم ميشال حدائق لابانيول
المصممه على الطراز الايطالي مصنفه ضمن
المعالم التاريخيه للبلاد
ماري هي صاحبه هذا المكان كل صباح تستمتع
بمشاهده هذه المناظر من نافذه قصرها
لا اترك ذلك ابدا واحيانا استغرب من عاده
اولئك الذين يفتحوننا وافدهم ليطلوا على
البحر غير اني اطل على جمال الريف المنظر
يتغير بتغير الفصول والتبدل احوال الطقس
ليس المنظر نفسه دائما
تحفه فنيه باتم معنى الكلمه تتطلب انامنا
بارع من دون شك جون بول هو كبير
البستانيين في هذه الحديقه اعتني بها
يوميا
انها بمثابه لوحه فنيه وسط المروج ليس من
الجيد ان نرى اشجارا او شجيرات ذات اشكال
غريبه مثل هذه
لابد من تقليمها كما نفعل الان
تطورت الحديقه على مر القرون وفقا لقواعد
الفن الاخضر فنلاح احتبابات القائم على
الجمال والهندسه
هل ترون هذه الاشكال المكعبه والحلزونيه
كل شيء تم قياسه بالضبط سواء كانت مسطحه
او عموديه لابد ان تكون مستويه تماما
للقيام بذلك نستخدم بعض الطرق مثل وضعنا
لعود الخيزران هذا كي نعرف مركز الشجيره
بعدها يجب الابتعاد قليلا عنها كي تتضح
الرؤيه افضل لان العين لها كذلك وظيفتها
في تعديل بعض الاخطاء
حديقه تسر الناظرين تفتن بسحرها كل عام
7000 سنه
الى الجنوب الفرنسي الان وبالضبط الى
مدينه انتيب حيث نرسل خطانا الى فيلا
ايلين الفاخره مبنى راقي تم تشييده في
اواخر القرن التاسع عشر وفقا مخطط المهندس
الذي صمم مبنى الاوبرا الفارسي لكن هنا كل
شيء مختلف
سلسله هذه اميره موناكو هل ترون انها ورده
انيقه وجميله وراقيه في الوقت نفسه
هذه
شهره هذا المنزل صنعتها من دون شك هذه
الحديقه المتنوعه تمتد على مساحه احد عشر
هكتارا وتفتح ابوابها مجانا للزوار لكن
الحال لم يكن كذلك في السابق
الدخول الى الحدائق لم يكن مجانيا في
نهايه القرن التاسع وكان يتم التبرع
بعائدات زوار للجمعيات الخيريه مثل
لاغودولي التي كانت تعمل على توعيه
الامهات الشابات بكيفيه ارضاع صغارهم عدم
فتح الحدائق امام عامه الناس كان نادرا
كانت هذه الارض مجرد كومه من الحجاره في
عام 1860 شيد رجل هولندي ثري هذه الفيلا
من اجل زوجته لكن الرياح جرت بما لا
تشتهيه السفن
كان القدر ضده لان المكان لم يعجب زوجته
فغادرت ومن شده يقال انه باع هذا المكان
كله بعشق قيمته
في سنوات الثلاثينيات صار المنزل وحدائقه
الغناء مكان التقاء الاثرياء من الناس وفي
عام
1982 تبرعت به صاحبته الى البلديه بشرط
واحد ان تظل الحديقه مفتوحه للجمهور ولكل
المفتونين بابها الحدائق في فرنسا
[موسيقى]